President Trump this week signed an
eight point three billion dollar
spending package to fight and treat
coronavirus the bill passed Congress
with overwhelming bipartisan support
were the only three GOP lawmakers voting
against it joining me right now is House
Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy he is a
Republican from California good to see
you sir thanks very much for being here
thanks for having the Republicans voting
against it I don't get that at all in
the middle of a crisis sir no and you'd
have to ask them but what's even worse
about this we should have we should have
had this bill a week earlier the
Democrats actually held this bill so
Congress won't Bustos who runs the
d-triple-c could run ads against
Republicans there should be no politics
in this because as you said Maria this
is very serious and we should take it
for the seriousness that it should be
eight point three billion dollars it
does three main things testing treatment
and telehealth which is very important
because what you want to do is make sure
you have containment but make sure these
people are able to get the treatment
they need and we were able to make a
revision in that where people to use
technology today to be able to talk to a
doctor not going out and affecting
everybody else around them and make a
real difference to this so are you gonna
be able to clear the decks in terms of
the vaccine I mean the bureaucratic
process in terms of getting drug passed
through the FDA is there anything you
can do differently in terms of hurrying
up to get a vaccine sooner rather than
later I know that there are therapies
that we're waiting on as well within the
next couple of months yes we're working
on this and down I just had a number of
companies in and remember they were with
the president this week as well when he
also went to NIH and CDC this is where
the ingenuity of American has solved the
problem just like Ebola we have a
vaccine for that now you have Gilead
already into trials in China and in
America on the best way for treatment
you have Johnson & Johnson and other
companies right now working on a vaccine
the real challenge here is that China
was not forthcoming was not allowing our
scientists our doctors in what President
Trump was requesting it early on in
December of last year and that's why we
weren't getting all the information that
you had a CDC kit testing not go out
right because we weren't getting the
right information now that we have it we
know every single day
something more about this and America
will solve this problem not just for
America but for the rest of the world
what does this mean for Zhi Jing ping I
mean first he had the Hong Kong
protesters now he's got this
he had swine flu he's dictator for life
he's got lots of plans for 2030 is this
enough to knock him off his perch I
don't know if it's enough to knock him
off his perch but you know his standing
has had had to have fallen along with
his country to deny our doctors to be in
there is now affecting the rest of the
world the other thing has own economy I
know it's a closed economy so how how
much will people actually know in
society but there are millions of people
who are out of work being told to stay
home and now every country is going to
look at their supply chain and we as
America should just as the President
Trump has asked us to do before our key
ingredients to our own medicines our
critical minerals to so many things we
make we're reliant upon China and we do
not want to have that happen when you
saw a problem just now and their net
weren't forthcoming they weren't open
about it where we could have contained
this inside China all right let me move
on to the economy here and the 2020
election obviously you're trying to take
back the house the GOP is you had great
numbers on jobs in February 273 thousand
jobs created in the month of February
you still see an economy that is strong
but there are wide and deep expectations
that things are gonna slow down in a big
way are you gonna come up with another
stimulus package a tax cut plan how are
you gonna deal with an economy that is
sure to slow as a result of everything
you just said in terms of manufacturing
in China well remember what we're
starting from the strongest economy we
had more than 50 years thanks to this
administration and the Republicans were
able to do on tax reform now because of
this disease I think you will see that
we're looking at things surgically areas
and industries that may need help and
that may be in a situation where you
relieve some regulations or tax but it's
something that we're studying now
because you're correct where we're
coming off more than 270 thousand jobs
when there's thought there'd be a
hundred thousand you look anywhere else
in the world they are jealous of what
America has been able to create and we
want to continue to maintain it the
challenge that we have is the Democrats
aren't
our will they do something to help the
economy grow or were they carrying more
about politics to try to harm this
president and we've watched time and
time again they always pick politics
that's why I always say if you want to
change the house you have to go to take
the house dot-com to make a fundamental
difference here but this is not a place
that there should be politics yes so you
should put people before politics you
just heard from Governor Cuomo he said
President Trump is afraid of Joe Biden
bottom line that's what the governor
just told us a few minutes ago you
called it on this program you said that
the Democrats are clearing the decks for
Biden and they're cluding against Bernie
again they are all getting behind Joe
Biden right now what are your prospects
going into 2020 election remember what
they did to Bernie Sanders four years
ago the night before the convention the
chair of the Democratic Party had to
resign because they found out they were
cheating Nancy Pelosi the Speaker of the
House held the papers and not a
Pietschmann not to go the Senate so the
Senators couldn't campaign to give an
advantage to Joe Biden
they got Klobuchar to back out and Budaj
edged to endorse beforehand but the one
thing they have to understand and
looking back as a Republican nominating
Joe Biden it's the same thing as
Republicans nominating mitt mitt romney
it may make the establishment feel good
but you have no chance of winning Wow
well what Mitt Romney's already you know
he almost stopped any any investigation
into Biden Joe hunter Biden right I mean
he's he's gonna be the vote that goes
against President Trump he's made that
clear yeah but this should not be about
politics any elected official that uses
their office or has their children who
uses their office to to get economic
gain where you're getting $50,000 a
month how many Americans don't make that
in a year and you have no experience
whatsoever and the only reason you have
that job is because of your father and
your father withholds money to a country
to change the investigation of the
people that hired you the Democrats
should be the first person investigating
this all they've done with their
majority is investigate but the only
place they wouldn't investigate is Joe
Biden because they care about politics
instead instead of the rule of law well
we've been waiting on Lindsey Graham to
call somebody down to subpoena hunter
bite and
subpoena somebody around this Shore we
haven't seen here you is this gonna be
investigated or not we got senator
Johnson out there asking for a subpoena
and rightfully so and it shouldn't be
about politics this should be about the
rule of law and that's exactly why it
should be carried out I would like to
see Democrats care about this too and
vote for this yeah
couch it real quick before you go and in
any reaction to what Senator Schumer
said and trying to attack a Supreme
Court justice and then in explaining it
he said hey I'm from Brooklyn by the way
I'm from Brooklyn I have a problem with
that
he is he saying that people from
Brooklyn threaten Supreme Court justices
he's saying more than that he is the
leader of the Senate he is a leader of
the Democrats he's standing before the
Supreme Court trying to influence the
outcome in America we believe we
encourage the exchange of ideas not to
the idea that you're going to intimidate
remember they dislike President Trump
from winning for winning so they
impeached him
they see college campuses so they go
after and try to intimidate them then we
watched what senator schumer was doing
yeah the intimidation there if I was a
Democrat in the Senate I would have
changed my leadership if this was what
was happening well and I would also keep
Brooklyn out of it Brooklyn rocks
congressman it's good to see you this
morning thank you sir